um i like the way it's been spun as a
radical proposition it it it sounds to
me like a party which doesn't know what
it stands for and and is prepared to say
anything to say one thing to uh
labour voters potential labour voters
like for example when it went all
red red ukip in with insurance and sale
and says plays the class war card as
it's current as
roger helm is currently doing in um in
newark
i don't think these are healthy
practices for
for the kind of party i want to believe
in which should ultimately
be about small government well i mean i
would just come back and say
you know you'll know bang on where we
stand starting in september doncaster
when we start rolling out some of the
ideas and thoughts for the general
election
manifesto i i think a lot of the
criticism recently has been that ukip's
talking too much about the eu and
immigration but actually you know it was
a european election campaign the other
party didn't want to talk about it you
could fought it on the actual issues
from september in doncaster you will get
an idea of policies
on subjects other than these two but the
ideology that we care in is actually
helping people
and not some academic debate it's what's
going on in the real world with jobs
and the pressures that people have sorry
not helping people what you're
absolutely
you're sounding like helping helping
people okay making sure they can get a
job making sure they don't have to worry
making sure they can look after their
family these are the real things
that's the job of government is it
government is to help people yourself
the government say that if the
government no they aren't there because
the other party is the same we'll have
as many people from around
the world and the eu as they want to
come and know the job
market gets completely saturated so
that's what they're all saying what
we're saying is put the british people
first i'm not just as an empty platitude
i mean gordon brown you know british
jobs for british workers is now saying
that he despises ukip
you're not even british people for i
mean that that that could almost be a
bnp slogan this is this is
what i'm not hearing you say michael
what you haven't said once is
i want government to get out of our
lives and
ukip will help do that if i heard that
from you i would be encouraged i haven't
heard
you say a word which encourages me about
about ukip at the moment well my
my main priorities personally apart from
the eu and immigration and grammar
schools and i think social mobility for
instance in this country is on its
on it's on its on its knees and rather
than have an academic debate about
factories you know factualism to me
you know i was born in 1989 it's simply
not relevant to people nowadays we
wanted to build a people's revolution
but for 2014 not in the 1980s